ninja star magnets and a cute doll that
gives birth it's episode 1 of loot
what's better than chairs chairs wearing
socks they stop floor scratches
squeaking and it never smell as bad as
yours do
oh look Tinkerbell oh wait nope that's
Hitler Bell and it can be yours for only
two hundred dollars too rich for your
blood then buy this painting for only
125 dollars it's called wishing well and
was painted with paint and the artists
own fecal matter speaking of food are
you looking to cut a pizza pie into
slices well cut it with pie no no no pie
the pizza cutter
the only things cooler are pie ice cubes
so cold their freezin erbium and
beryllium two great elements that can be
mixed to form a fun compound beer so why
not have it on your pint glass look how
happy and cross-eyed it made this guy
Nick see sticks are like pixie sticks
except they're caffeinated each tube is
the equivalent of a cup of coffee not
impressed then by some Ed Hardy coffee
rocks a box of bees is equal to three
cups of coffee if you'd rather just have
coffee drink it out of this teeth mug
from Yanko design every time you take a
sip that'll feel like you're making out
with a hot girl who doesn't have any
lips that 19 brings us some silly putty
it bounces it stretches it rips oh and
it's filled with millions of micron
sized magnetic particles making it
magnetic the putty comes with a magnet
that when left on top of the putty gets
eaten alive if of course magnets were
alive but now let's play some games
Donkey Kong Jenga Scrabble Jenga a
travel Rubik's Cube keychain and of
course a game you win by making a dog
poop do you like to cook chicken and
stuff animals will no problem wrap neato
shops grilled chicken plush and yes the
velcro legs can be ripped off for
snacking visiting Sweden soon make
reservations in the mirror cube a
treehouse built to appear invisible
while giving you the guy inside a
360-degree view of nature at all
and if you get cold just sling on your
Cabbage Patch doll Irma's they're not
creepy at all planning a vacation to a
warmer place we'll make sure to bring
your c-3po one-piece swimsuit or if
you're like me and you have two
girlfriends be sure to pick up an r2d2
soon as well
do you like cupcakes but wish they were
more evil or will check out noms goals
you can bake cupcakes in a school that
look like brains they make this kid do a
no face time for our free thing classic
orb it works on PCs and Macs and turns
your computer and any external drives
attached to it into a private streaming
machine to your cell phone or any gaming
console or use it to remotely turn on
your computer's webcam from anywhere in
the world who knows what we'll find
thanks for watching episode 1 of Luke
there's gonna be a lot more on vsauce2
after the holidays but until then be
sure to subscribe and as always thanks
for watching